[Music]
ah
i remember we left off and i was looking
at this beautiful castle being like i
want to know what it
is we'll get there one day when we do
it'll be a glorious day
so i saw a video on youtube and it was
like what happens if you throw
a pipe bomb at the duke and now i really
want to do it so um
do i have a pipe bomb
no when when we get them can i shoot at
him i feel like we need to
preserve ammo though
but when we get one and one that's you
know
one that we don't need we're gonna have
to do that because i need to figure out
what i need to see what he does
can i go behind this curtain no
okay so
that is the way we came when we came in
so we're going to go up these grand
stairs
ah i do love just the decor of this game
excuse me it looks so pretty as well
oh a blood stained mug
can we not do anything with it
no i'm just looking at the blood
okay
are you sure it just seems weird that we
can just
okay i guess we were just checking out
the blood
uh
ah so the seeds back out there
oh can i smash anything smashy smashy
give me back rose
anything here can i turn on a flashlight
do i have one
i don't think i can go through this door
the wine making techniques of castle de
matrisk can be traced as far back as the
15th century
long before the current occupants of the
castle alkena de micro
dimitrisk uses this legendary yet
peculiar technique to enrich the wine's
flavor intensity and bestow
it with a thick bouquet her best vintage
is
meaning maiden's blood it is kept in a
special ornate bottle decorated with
intricate silver flowers so i guess it's
like what we saw
on the cup is her special wine and my
theory
is that rose is a maiden
um i mean she's she's a baby
but um she wants frozen's blood for her
special wine possibly
special baby wine
whoa this wine is freaking
indestructible no wonder she wants to
make so much of it
all right all right
mmm gunpowder
do you ever when you play games just
find a really nice scene and then just
start like doing like slow pan arounds
and stuff like you're
directing a movie all the time
oh especially in the witcher i love
doing it in the witcher in witcher 3.
if any of you follow me on instagram
you'll just every now and then you just
get like stories of um
me doing little pan arounds of geraldton
fancy fields
with a dragon behind him or something
hello all right let's give you an eye
this is where the fun begins
i haven't cut open a man in a while why
am i going to get picked
let me string you up slice your jugular
watch nah take it live i think
dad which would you prefer you will look
wonderful mounted in our hall
yep uh okay
nope i don't think i can kill those i
think all i can do
is run away and i really do not want to
waste my ammunition
so i don't even want to try if i'm
honest
it was my first day working at the
castle today i was most shocked to see
the other staff were all women
the mistress and her daughters were very
adamant that they wouldn't bite
it was quite peculiar
it's been two weeks since i started
working at the castle and i'm a little
afraid another maid adella made a
mistake and miss daniella slashed her
face with a knife
just a little afraid i'd be freaking
terrified
and at night i hear her wailing as if
ghosts roam the halls
i want to go home i don't know what to
do
the young ladies were complaining it was
too hot and stuffy during dinner so i
opened the window just to crack
shut it shut it now they all creaked at
me in unison
i fear i may be taken down into the
cellar never to be seen
up again i don't know what to do i don't
know what to do wow
i guess it was daytime and she was
letting the light in
and then obviously these maidens were
just being used
to make this special indestructible wine
okay
i look freaking ridiculous in this thing
um okay she just left
oh
thank you icon i wouldn't i would not
have noticed
anything else in here oh what's down
what's on here
what is this baby chickens
baby chicks chick chick fetuses
chickpea tie
oh man that's a bit dark okay
can't go out that way
see when i first played the demo of this
i just figured everything with yellow
tape on it
could be breakable and everything else
couldn't but no the game is just
trolling
it's like yes but also no
so i didn't realize that you could um
you could break like the the white
ceramic vases and stuff
yes this is how we put things on fire we
just knock them with our head
oh god i can't see anything okay thank
god
what oh god
so he turns his light on automatically
by the way that wasn't me
turning it off and on
did i just go in this one or was it
another one
help me brother
uh
um
let me in i need to go poo poos
oh what's happening with this texture
very shimmery i don't think he wants to
look in there properly so we're just
getting it all blurred
ethan's like no what are you doing i
don't want to see this
what's in the bowl
the door's scaring me right
candidates harina mihaila
louis ingrid rejects
dandora greta nadine camellia
bianca molina astrid laid mila
rosalinda liner stefan
oh my god thank you for hosting
john the tank that scared the hell on me
so freaking loud what
okay so tests were done here
but they were done on male and female
because that cells that helped me
brother
so i'm guessing it was made
written by a man perhaps
irena a robust appetite we had a robust
appetite ingrid is unstable and overly
alert at times
great they're all hungry hungry for
blood
i am guessing not good for me
not good for me
hmm i see you game
nope
nope nope nope oh no no
no actually
and mine isn't a bad idea
maybe we should save it one
such a worse when i'm tired
my lazy brain is like i can't be
bothered
that was a some very important metal
scrap that i've just found
thanks for following marble iris oh
jesus
oh jesus jesus
oh [ __ ] die die
die die die [ __ ]
[Applause]
now i can use this again
[Applause]
i got a crystal skull [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god oh my god
i know where i'm supposed to go down
there but like there's things around
oh [ __ ] ass hats
oh my god it's everywhere
i need to go find it i can't give up
no break it break it get it get it
break it get it okay switch guns
come on me [ __ ]
where's all the crap that i missed
where is this crystal skulls and stuff
aha here
okay i think i got everything
i'm not leaving without my phil
how are you not dead yet
you are so bloody
did i get it i don't even know
this is nice place this is a nice place
to fight because i can see
wait do they not like the light because
that's really good
they probably don't do they
i know i don't need to kill them all but
i feel like i need to
great job
[Music]
oh that's ingrid that's that's a real
good one that one
oh my god i'm getting so into this now
i love how in the beginning i'm like
[Music]
tired
that's fun
there's so much stuff in here i love it
like i could have just chickened out
and just ran through but no let me go
i'm so proud of myself
picking myself up here right uh
did i get everything this place is like
a maze
but it was really fun to fight in
because i never felt cornered
okay i think i got everything
hell yeah
okay nice one that before we continue
off
jesus every time i go to press the
middle thing
to get the menu up and it shoots the
bloody gun um
let's make some stuff
can you make shotgun yes
and i need some help that would be very
nice thank you
um i don't have anything i want to go in
there
all right let's look for a lockpick guys
we can do this
cassandra caused all this mess oh [ __ ]
oh no i know
how am i gonna get around you blood out
when they're alive
and it's that much okay okay
you're tonight's main dish whatever
i'm acting like a teenager whatever mama
don't care
where are you going little one
[Applause]
your stupid man thing
i don't care about you i need some
bullying
you've blocked me in here now you little
[ __ ] can i please get past
okay i'll slice your throat
and stuff it with worms oh dear i don't
know what i'm supposed to be doing
i guess i've already
shot that one
i'm sick of fighting you yes
oh
not like
my trusty shotgun i just had to believe
it my trusty
sweet
shotgun did the job
okay kind of wasted uh
some bullets and stuff well not really i
guess
can i make any more nice
i love this guy oh girl
oh no binary pal
oh yeah i forgot about his hand oh
it's the special wine
another one was sent to the cellar she
only had spilled some soup
everyone knows what happens when you're
sent to the cellar you're never seen
again
they drain your blood your soul cursed
to wander the halls
i went looking for her and when i found
her she was just skin and bones
and gnawing on a rat carcass i suspect
it'll be my turn next
nice what about baby
chick fetuses is anyone gnawing on the
baby chick fetuses
or is that just lady demetrius maybe
that's her little
snack snack it's like a choice
so can i see what i picked up earlier
all right so i've got this i can have a
look at this special special wine
oh it's got a very fancy cork
that is a cork
aha this is what i wanted to look at
crystallize remains of a sharp franged
creature oh so it's actually from them
demetrius daughters crystallized remains
that's so cool
see that did not happen in the demo
necklace of animal bones used to ward
against evil
can i wear it
i guess it doesn't work though cuz
ingrid was evil
treasure
hmm
what was that for
sweet
aha a lock pick
can we go all the way back to that room
yes guys i'm going to take you all the
way back if i can i don't think i can
though i think this door is locked
well we can use it on this at least
maybe i'll buy some lock picks from the
duke you probably do that right
what an angel statue
i really do like admiring stuff in this
game it's really nice
oh should we should we break things
whoa
[Music]
the freaking windows like this i mean i
just did it before but i thought that
was just
for that one part of the gameplay
so cool
i'm back
oh now what
did the maiden go into one of these
statue guys wait let's have a look and
see if
can we put it into one of these
no
welcome welcome you're sure to find
something new
as you wish
okay i've procured some new items for
you mr winters
what is this
oh right i don't need that yet i think
we're good for
slots in my inventory
sniper rifle ammo i mean i don't have a
sniper rifle yet so
i think we're okay for now
yes learning how to make mine yes
okay that's basically all my money gone
now till next we meet
oh you can't shoot at him
oh i don't know i can't stop thinking
about it screw it
what i just wasted my black bum nothing
happened
okay let's go
so where to now
i wonder
hello
lady dimitrisk is going is that how i
say demetrius
dimitris it's going to be
not very happy when she realizes that a
i've
gone and b i have killed one of her
daughters
oh i know where i've got to go debbie
depp jabs i've got the wine
special wine
courtyard key
key is that on the room where i smash
the windows
possibly yes
probably yes
shall i give you the two words oh jesus
no
no thank you oh god no no no no
no no no no
i just really don't want to okay here we
go
hurry up please see ya sucker
wait is she ready just gonna stay in
there and not do anything
bye okay
wait are they like random do they roam
the hallways of the
of the mansion because that's quite cool
if they do
well at least we know that we're safe
out here because they don't like the
light
thank you
[Music]
i'm sorry uh
so many doors
um
i actually didn't expect to be able to
open this door either
[Music]
thanks for reading the channel princess
letters
i kind of want to just go back outside
to explore everything else but i'm not
going to i'm just going to carry on come
on
let's do this
yeah she won't hear this
yeah this will help me
what have you done to my daughter
i am you don't hurt me
oh no i told you guys she was gonna be
really mad
it'd be locked i have a map
how do i open the map
this one
the whole of a blue
there's a hall of pleasure there uh
a hall of ablution
oh this is the matresk's chambers
are we gonna go in there
oh damn is this a pool of blood
oh
oh
gotta tan them different ways
i don't know why oh women are blind to
male
advances but the poor shall take their
chances
to give their lord their bounty sewn so
to soon the wine may flow
women are blind to male advances but the
poor shall take their chances to give
their lord their bounty sewn
so that soon the wine may flow okay so i
need to
move these guys to look at the lord
there we go
nice
just keep progressing don't we okay um
is that a potty seat like did you just
sit on here and just go potty
that's a bit weird is that actually what
it is
oh my gosh i think it is guys it's like
a potty seat
this lady demonstrates a little potty
seat
yes please are we gonna come face to
face with her
here no we're not no we just heard her
getting angry
okay
and i'm sure she's totally fine with us
just
you know tearing our way through her
house
then again she has got our daughter yeah
we can't forget that
she she's the one in the wrong here
let me just see if i can make anything
can i make you oh yeah
i've only got one chem fluid i'll see
what i need later on
hello
[Music]
no yes
what the hell did you just notice
that you've been bathing in blood
because you did it just now as well
ethan
you didn't care then
oh no barricade door
oh i don't trust any of this crap
okay
oh jesus
i don't like it i don't
jesus christ
i couldn't i couldn't turn around fast
enough you're too good for me
these people love their wine
ah
i'm liking this faster reload speed oh
geez
hey look hello
hello
ethan just constantly bumping things
with his head
yep i see i see you
okay nice so i can just look out for
little ripples in the water okay okay we
got this we got this we got this we got
it we got this
where did you come from where did you
come where did you come from
just get back up
oh nice
how's my house
oh yeah don't forget we call that
platform
let me go to mine hello
constantly just keeping you on guard
little knocks and creeks and stuff
any ripples oh okay
here i was looking behind me
somehow they seemed easier to kill and
i'm not sure why because i didn't
increase the power on the gun or
anything
oh pretty we're back out in the
prettiness
oh thank you again so good to me
this
hello
she is
mother miranda i regret to inform you
that ethan winters has
escaped that fool heisenberg
because he is in my castle and has
already proven too much for my daughters
to handle
when i find him
no mother miranda yes
of course i understand the importance of
the ceremony
i won't let you down
to hell with a ceremony that man
will pay for what he's done
okay lady demetrius don't like us
we're not the favorite we're not we
haven't done good things here
i mean we have been absolutely wrecking
her castle as well
[Music]
so this is her height damn
woo
she's big
nice rose
where are you oh so that's where rose
was
presumably and maybe she has another
baby but probably not
uh we are all called by mother maid
mother miranda to decide the fate of the
child's father
oh that's me they're talking about me
just thinking of that
family meeting makes me shudder to think
i am treated like a sister to those
miscreants especially heisenberg that
riff-raff wouldn't know
proper manners if they slapped him in
the face he would have
i would have sliced into ribbons if
mother hadn't stopped me why
why did she treat me the same as them
she gave me this castle
obedient daughters everlasting life does
she not
am i not her favorite am i not special i
need a drink
she went
oh [ __ ]
all this for a child who isn't even here
what the hell do you ungrateful
selfish wretch you come into my house
you lay your filthy man hands on
my daughters and now you even try to
steal
my property
just a few bullets rest while you
can because i will hunt you
and i will break you
oh what why didn't you just break me
just then do your worst
put me down through the floor
okay great
oh
i think it's time to make a bit more of
that
where are we
we've been here before right no maybe
not then
it all looks the same over here
nice nice
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
my right hand is a bloody unusable
wait what am i supposed to do now oh god
keep going keep going
don't die don't die don't i don't i
don't die i have so much to live for i
have so
much to live for go keep going
keep going i can't believe the hand
thing again
god ethan what is it with you and not
being able to keep your hands
go go go jesus christ is taking so long
oh my god where am i
running will get you nowhere
i mean it went last time so why not now
oh my gosh it's like vile
good this castle
oh
oh god
you're stupid you didn't even know i was
i don't really know where i'm going
so all these doors can be opened by the
ladies with this key
nicely
nothing in here
wait is this why i went when i initially
saw her
i think i can hear her walking around or
something
i can hear something
oh god this is so tense
there's something around here
is it down there oh there's a piano
i have a flower swords full
what taking off this hat
look it's another one of these fancy
castle things
oh maybe i can use it if i go back to
the duke and i can go inside
this is a ball
exciting
one day since treatment the tree
the the tree the three girls have
stopped moving they almost seemed
dead an insect flew out of the eldest
mouth
it appears to be a common fly two days
since treatment
all three bodies are covered in flies it
appears the flies are consuming their
flesh
when i opened a window some of the flies
dropped dead to the floor
it had seen it seems the cold petrifies
them
also they're not quite vampires then
they're like bug bug girls um
i quickly close the window to avoid
weakening the insects rather
four days since treatment all three
bodies have almost
been completely consumed by the insects
all that is left is a dark
writing human-shaped mass of creatures
it is just
afternoon and the insects have started
to change color
those around the face turned pale and
those on the lips turned a
deep crimson so their skin got replaced
with
bugs whoa
the mass of insects have transformed
into human bodies again
all three girls awoke looking at me like
newborns i sense
a bond between us like mother and
daughters i have already decided their
names
bella daniela and cassandra which one
did i kill then
let's have a look at the pictures oh
these pictures are really nice
that's strange so that's lady dimitresk
and mother miranda holding like
that's the fetus thing the fetus thing
that we've been seeing the fetus logo
and she's like holding her fetus out
towards her
and then there they are that's that's
the three
letters in all their glory
um being consumed by
insects
do they all look the same because if
they do that would make
sense because they're all just basically
made up of the other mass of
insects
i know i know i'm running out of ammo
an easy to pick block if you have a
lockpick i want to go down to the piano
room
should i be killing like all of these i
feel like i probably shouldn't but also
i just want to i probably shouldn't um
cute cat in that picture
i can play
[Music]
sorry i don't know why every now and
then my my game will just
pause like this
no no no no jesus no
do i have to play the tune
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh go ethan yes
beautiful
scientific name none size
5 to 6 centimeters similar body
structure to blow flies
although there are differences in the
head they are carnivorous and
vigorously consume meat in order to
catch unsuspecting prey they'll gather
use gather gather using pheromones to
mimic a brain
no remember human they are produced when
a caddo cato lies
eggs in its hosts but the flies
themselves are unable to reproduce they
are weak to sudden drops in temperature
especially if the temperature drops
below 10 degrees
their metabolism lowers and they go
dormant they go into a dormant
cry cryptobiotic state similar to the
cryptobiosis of
tardigrade or okay
so they're made out of these blowflies
well no actually they don't have a
scientific name
but they're carnivorous flies and they
have laid eggs
in the girls that's disgusting
like how there's always scrap in the
fireplace it's very nice
can i open this door
unlock it perfect
oh this is the way it came okay so i
guess that's
this place checked out
i've got the key from here so that's
good at least
bloody everywhere
okay so that's back into the main
place this is the door that i went into
i do believe
as they delayed um i just went up
that way so i came
out from the floor
but i don't think
i have gone this way
not wasting any more money
this game brings out a new side
i know this is back into the main castle
that's not a door
i don't think the game wants me to stay
still for too long
do you just get the impression
okay i'm coming in
even though i feel so much safer out
there
okay i have this key
what what where is that noise from i
don't even know
do i have anything for you yet yes i
have a mask of sorrow so i need to find
um
oh yeah you're perfect
i also have a flower sword spot oh
the castle thing oh perfect
hello duke i am it's a pleasure to see
you safe
how were things no sign of rose
i'm so sorry it turned out that way
well you'll find your way to her once
you're out of this castle
do you have need of anything for the
road ahead
i've expanded my services please come
take a look
wait let me do this first
what supposed to tilt it
cool not interested i suppose
oh this is so cool
cute little mini game
oh i did it wrong okay
oh i see there's like little holes
before the main hole so i need to try
and get it too
yes did it
[Music]
oh is that it i mean it was cool i
just i don't know i don't know what i
was expecting like
that we would shrink in size and go into
a
like a little porcelain weird dimension
world but
this is so cool so seem to be doing
okay so far not not that bad
i don't know i'm sure some of you think
like otherwise you're just like what
what
but well then feel free to peruse
so i guess i can sell that one yeah i
can sell this one
oh stop it duke stop it stop it
i hate the noises it makes oh
sorry i'm doing neck stretches i'm on
the computer all the time nowadays my
neck is paying for it
uh oh yes look at this
so much crystallized human remains found
in the labyrinth in castle dimitrisk
very valuable well i guess i will sell
her crystal i feel bad i don't know why
i feel bad selling a torso i feel like i
need it for some reason i definitely
don't do i but
i feel like i do
why would i buy another gun
oh no that's sell well don't be dumb
dabs right
so i'm not gonna sell i'll just sell
this
now to spend like kings
please do take a look at my new stock
okay
hmm should i shoot ammo capacity
or should i do power my shotty
power these hands are more dexterous
than one might think
i feel like if i buy this it's gonna
save me
in the long run but then maybe maybe not
i don't know
i can still buy that if i wanted to
well i could just buy some some shotgun
ammo
it's um it's quite cheap
can i get this yet
thank you for your purchase
i got that
yeah i'll leave the sniper rifle ammo
because i don't feel like i need it
yet and
screw it
oh it's for one one thousand for one
bullet
that's quite a lot yeah
i hate i can't stand his noises
that's so disgusting
please come again yeah i just i just
spent a lot of money
but you loved it okay shall i save
and stop playing
now we'll go on for a little bit longer
guys see
see what's next if i can figure out
where i'm going
okay so we got dimitrusk's key and we
have this one now
so where have we seen this door before
probably i wonder
anywhere back here that was locked that
we couldn't actually get to
probably jesus
christ
going outside i'm going outside cause i
know you don't like the windows
bye
i was not expecting anything to get me
there i was like oh this is a dead piece
of you know
no one's ever here anymore and then
wait no there was a door there with like
a coffin right
yes this is the door with the coffin and
i needed a key for it
[Applause]
i'm
don't like this music that's over this
[Music]
music
[Applause]
anything
uh
okay so that's everyone down here and
that was a lot of bullets
here
okay oh nice we've got another pipe bomb
now we don't have to be too precious
about
very very it
kind of want to try and blow up this
wall but also i don't want to waste the
pipe bomb
but i do feel like that's what we've got
to do because there's fire behind here
right
oh should i
can i not just do everything with my
knife
oh no i do think they gave us that pipe
bomb to use it here
unless could
can i light you with these tiny little
candles
ethan
no
okay i'm gonna try this and if it
doesn't work i'm gonna be ready upset
it works okay okay okay that wasn't a
complete waste
waste of a pipe bomb
but how do i swing this guy up there
i gotta be able to surely
does that work this is really finicky
why can't i just grab
a hold of the bottom of it or something
what's stupid
no this is stupid there's got to be a
better way
keep pushing it the wrong way
okay i think i'm gonna give up
that's annoying
so annoying hopefully i'll find
maybe a stick or something that i can
set fire see why can't i just
pick this up
oh i'm not going all the way down here
screw that
liam wants me to try and shoot it shoot
what this
oh my gosh thank you
i would not have thought of that
i don't want to shoot i don't want to
waste all my bullets
come on
surely we can just push these two
together how is ethan not on fire
there we go nice
hopefully this is worth it
where else do we need an eye
hmm i guess that room is nice and warm
so if we killed that one daughter in
that room with the billowing
smoke and what you know the cold air
maybe we can kill the others as well if
we can lure them into these roots
uh
okay the music got very intense then for
a second
so we have an eyeball what a wonderful
thing to have
what do we do with it
trying to walk up my appetite now are
you nope
nope nope nope please say you do not
kill me when i'm in with the duke
we're about to find out
hey duke please save me from scary bug
lady
it worked nice well then
feel free to peruse i don't have
anything to give you oh yeah i do
actually i'm not giving you that
bits and bobs i see
i look forward to seeing the fruits of
your exploration
yeah yeah yeah
what about the locked door up here my
memory is
shot and i can't remember
if it needed a key like the one that we
have
no it's just an elevator nothing happens
okay
why stop it where's the door
i'd love it if she said something when i
was in here like
oh hiding with the duke i see run away
to daddy duke running away to daddy duke
again
um so what have i found i found
two keys dimitrisk's key iron insignia
key
and that is it so far
i wonder if anything was actually back
here because i started to go back here
and then
we got we got disturbed
by a lady of flies
a lady of the flies screwed lord of the
flies lady of the flies
she's everywhere i just feel like she's
never gonna leave me alone
why do i come back here this is a
mistake take it back
i don't want to be here mother
mother
what
daddy duke save me please
i feel like she's just gonna come back
to get me but i'm just
i'm getting she's too freaked out
[Music]
two do you need an eyeball say have one
my health is good we're good we're good
we're good i'm just being a worse don't
worry about it
don't worry about it just to be in a
wuss
all right let's go up here
there is a locked door here
oh it's locked from the side
jeans
i hate you
how's it feel
sisters
come get no thank you
oh thank god she's not coming in hahaha
i got a silver ring
oops
okay so i can put that back on to open
it if i want to but
i can already see an escape so i don't
think i will
cool where are we oh
that was the hall of pleasure wow wow
wow hey i'll drank
941 thank you for following
i thought that suit obama behind the box
of the person
freaked me out
oh thank you
you're the best you're the best you're
the best we have so much ammo
i feel invincible and that's probably
maybe extremely cool i was worried my
sisters have gotten too close
you're in the way
maybe i'll keep a souvenir
no
that's the first time i died though i'm
actually pretty happy with that
at least we at least we didn't i thought
we'd end up back with duke
we're already here that's all right
okay so let's get our shoddy out
[Music]
i was worried my sisters have gotten too
first
what the [ __ ] is this
no you're
uh wait wait i need to get some iron
i'd like that
you've ruined the hunt
no it's a lie
brave
wait is she dead i'm crazy
[Music]
oh it was giving me pipe bombs anyway
okay that's good
oh good i love her before i died i was
like
i have so much ammo i feel invincible
and as i was saying that i was like yeah
i'm
definitely gonna die soon because i just
jinxed myself
tried to use the shotgun to blow up the
wall but that was a pretty stupid idea
that treasure oh no
i did something
okay let's see
good
oh i put one on the floor i wish i could
pick it back up
oh i know what i can do i can replace
the old head with
with this one
thanks for following lammer lammer
oh three
i am not doing good
let's take it off
foreign
just like that's the idea of pleasure
i ain't gonna judge
what a bad time to bump into her
oh that shot of her just walking past
the stairs that gave me
ripples is she coming
she's so beautiful
okay go run i just want to watch her
she's so beautiful wait which one's a
pleasure
angela
[Music]
save me that was so stupid for me
hey
i think i just um i think i just pulled
a muscle on my leg
[Music]
she's still out here
i think she's walked off
oh i like that i like that we can like
creep behind her and she doesn't know
we're here
we never really got to do that with like
mixed directs or anything
i'm playing i'm playing with fate here
i shouldn't do this i'm going i'm
leaving
yeah i'm leaving i'm going
hello okay so we've got an eyeball
yes it's me oh good i was just thinking
of ways to pass the time
well how about some crystal torsos i'll
finally give them to you
oh i have a lock pick i didn't realize
that
this satisfied i believe this is a fair
price
i've procured some new items for you mr
winters
let's why not
i hope this one makes it this will help
because i was i was just whining about
that
okay uh
yes
till next we meet
okay and
this is where i'm gonna call it for
today guys
so thank you so much thank you
for watching i will see you this time
next week
8 30 p.m bst on youtube
and on twitch i'm jagman x on everything
if you want to see the first part it is
up
see you soon and have a lovely day or
evening